all of life works on responsibility
everybody listening to this program has
achieved what they've achieved in life
because they took responsibility to make
it happen government's no different than
that hi I'm Nick gesp with reason TV and
today we're talking with Philip K Howard
he's the author most recently of the
rule of nobody saving America from dead
laws and broken government Philip Kay
Howard thanks for talking to Reas nice
to be with you all right well let's get
right to it uh you know what when did uh
uh the death of Common Sense come out
1995 okay so you know you basically 20
years ago you helped launch a
conversation about the rule of kind of
top- down or automatic regulation in
American Life uh of of Politics on
autopilot and and we're still in the
thick of this uh but it seems like your
message might finally be getting through
that we we need to really change things
in the rule of nobody one of the things
that you talk about again and again in
compelling fashion are just these
examples where we don't even know who to
turn to the government doesn't even know
who to turn to when they need to get
things done talk a little bit about the
Kil van call uh which is one of the
opening anecdotes of your so in in in
2008 the Port Authority realized that uh
the new generation of ships post
pandemic ships were not going to fit
into newerk Harbor because uh the main
Bri Bridge they have to pass under the
Bayon Bridge was 65 ft too low the
bridge had been built 80 years ago it's
like the fourth largest single span uh
bridge in the you know in in in the
world uh so they uh commission studies
and the studies came back say well
either build a new bridge a new tunnel
it's going to cost four or five billion
dollars uh to do this wreak en
environmental havoc on the communities
and and such and it won't be finished in
time for the the new ships in any event
um you know the the environmental review
wouldn't be done for a decade um and the
person in charg of the project lifelong
uh Port Authority employee say well is
it possible that we could just raise the
roadway within the existing 80-year-old
bridge and I sort of raise their
eyebrows probably not but we'll go look
at it a couple of months later they came
back yes we can not only can we raise
the roadway within this existing single
single arch of the bridge um but we can
use existing foundations or structurally
sound and not change the RightWay we
just have to raise it a little bit so
it's like a miracle instead of four or
five billion was going to cost $1
billion and you don't even have to
rejigger every yeah yeah nothing nothing
gets rejiggered it was just brilliant it
would be and it should be ready in time
for the Post pandemic ships that was
2009 in the middle of
2013 four years later over four years
later uh they were were still arguing
over how much environmental review was
required groups had decided that this
should they should study the effects of
a more efficient port on the citizens of
Newark which is seven miles away
right having nothing to do with the
environmental effects of the bridge
itself which is sort of what the laws
intended to to to protect against
finally it got approved over these
objections and of course what's happened
they've started a lawsuit so now lawsuit
is pending right and I mean part of it
is I mean the way you talk about it is
that the people in charge of these
operations don't even know who to turn
to to expedite things or who's in charge
can you talk a little bit about that
where there's this vast diff I mean
there are is a a blanket of rules that
cover every move and then there's kind
of a fog where you don't even know who
is enforcing this rule or that rule
right so it's environmental review in
this country is a process no one's in
charge MH and so the Port Authority said
okay well under the rules we need a
quote lead agency to to to oversee our
environmental review of this this
project well who's going to be the lead
agency nobody in the federal government
has the authority to do that so they
send letters out to all these different
agencies and they drop out and finally a
year later the Coast Guard is the last
one standing and they agree to be the
lead agency then they have public
meetings on well how much should we
study again no one's in charge of
actually saying well how much did you
study so they public meetings or
arguments back and forth that goes on
for another year then they make a list
of all the legal requirements that that
of things that must be studied no matter
what and one of them is you have to do a
survey of historic buildings within two
miles of the of the bridge well the
bridge isn't going to touch any historic
buildings it's the same right away but
you still have to do that but you still
have to do it the law says you have to
do this so they then they have to go
through a procurement process
it's the government which is its own
neutral process to find a consultant to
do the survey of historic buildings
which is completely unnecessary that
takes a year and and many more so uh in
in a different context in the book you
talk about how the president and the
executive branch as the as the head of
the executive branch doesn't really have
very much authority over all of the
agencies or Personnel that he oversees
talk a little bit about that right so at
one point the regional office of envir
enal Protection Agency was making noises
that maybe you need a full environmental
review to study the effects on the
citizens of Newark meanwhile the
president of the United States President
Obama uh issues a statement declaring
this bridge is one of the top priorities
in the country to get done for the
economy and for jobs right away he
issues this statement that this is going
to be a top priority and two weeks later
the regional office of EPA sends a
letter
to the Port Authority saying we're still
not satisfied and we think you should do
a full-blown environmental review it'll
take another 5 years who are they
working for they supposedly work for the
president who's in charge of this show I
mean no one's no one's in charge and so
it's this is literally it's a ship
without a captain and it's you know
environmental rules are among the most
kind of Arcane and Byzantine but it's
it's not just about you know it's not
just green whack jobs it's all aspects
of kind of government uh Authority yeah
yes and so and so one of the things that
I write about in the book is how the
president of the United States actually
doesn't have the authority to run the
executive branch he can't except for a
very small number of appointees he can't
hire and fire who he wants he can't
really even tell people what to do
because it's all kind of dictated by
this accretion of law um which is built
up to keep the analogy like sediment in
the harbor right so it's this is a
problem that's much worse now even than
it was 20 years ago and it'll be worse
even worse 20 years in the future oh 20
years in the future I mean we're already
nearly paralyzed we won't be be able to
do anything uh by the way is this this
broadly uh observed throughout kind of
advanced economies is this uh just kind
of like this stage of uh of liberal
democracy uh it's a problem in in most
western democ
democracies uh but it's worse in our
country than the other other countries
have figured out ways to to begin to
deal with it by Sunset laws law things
like that um you know another great
example of kind of just insane
regulation of minute things uh talk
about Kansas retirement
homes so so nursing homes in this
country um first let me see nursing
homes require oversight right you know
know half the people have dementia you
don't want to put your granny or your
parents in a nursing home that's abusive
so government oversight i' argue is
important for Freedom at some level but
the way it works in this country is that
most states have a thousand or more
rules right that say things like food
must be stored no less than 9 cm above a
floor there should be trash cans in
every waste basket you know there should
be eggs eggs must be cooked eggs must be
cooked there should be 0 recreational
workers you know per employee per some
period of time I mean you know it's it's
it's
unbelievably uh you call it micro
regulation uh and and nursing homes in
this country are horrible the people go
through the day trying to comply
inspectors come by periodically they
don't even try to evaluate whether it's
a nice place or they're kind to the
residents what they evaluate is whether
all the Box have been right or and if
the food is only 6 cm off the floor we
got to shut it down or or you get a
ticket yeah you know in in this final
kind of instance of where it's not even
clear who's running the show uh you talk
about a and I'm I'm blanking now was a
$50
million uh was it a Reformatory or a
prison or a former mental institution in
New York state that Andrew CUA wanted to
shut down so so when Andrew CU got
elected uh he New York like all states
has these significant budget problems in
part because of the accretion of Law and
all the sort of pension benefits and
things that have kind of piled up over
the years and he discovered that there
was this Juvenile Detention Facility
Upstate that cost $50 million a year to
run M and there were no juveniles in it
it was empty and had no prospects of
being used so he said to say well this
is easy we're just going to shut this
down we're going to save $50 million
right away not so soon it turns out that
there's a law
um that requires that for any public
facility with Union employees there has
to be at least one year's notice before
a facility can be shut down so he wasn't
allowed to shut it down so the taxpayers
had to pay another $50
million uh I think that's 10,000
families paying each $5,000 each extra
in taxes that year to pay for a facility
of no use whatsoever because of a law
there's basically a kind of Union
feather beding law um medicare's early
days you have you know we everybody
recognizes now or seems to recognize
that Medicare the federal government's
uh Health Care system for elderly people
the single-payer system for elderly
people is just you know one of the
things that is beggaring the nation uh
you know it's going to double in in
before 2040 it's going to double in the
uh number of enroles it's going to cost
us more uh double the amount of money
we're paying per person per year per
enrol um you talk about the early days
of Medicare about how doctors and
providers game the system to squeeze
kind of maximize money talk a little bit
about that and then we'll talk about
where this kind of mentality comes from
and how to address it so so Medicare was
was enacted in
1965 it actually the bill was done over
a weekend the main Bill and they and
they copied an Etna um plan and
basically it introduced the idea of
government providing a kind of fee for
service reimbursement to people taking
care of the elderly and uh and they had
modeled a little bit the numbers of what
it would cost based on existing cost of
of healthc care and they had a certain
numbers for it and so the bill was
enacted a year later the people who
wrote the bill went out in the field to
see how it was working what they
discovered is that all the cost modeling
had been thrown out the window because
doctors and hospitals had radically
changed the way they practice medicine
they were now practicing medicine to
maximize reimbursement not not
surprisingly so they discovered things
like gang visits to nursing homes where
doctors would go to a nursing home and
you know a whole row of of experts and
they would each see an elderly person
and do an evaluation for a few minutes
and then collect whatever the designated
Fe was for that and uh we're getting
rich yeah you know off of this and so
they knew a year into it that this was
going to turn into a budgetary nightmare
but in the culture of lawmaking in this
country nobody ever goes back and
actually adapts or changes the law based
on actual experience and so yeah now now
now 40 50 years later it's uh on the
verge of bankrupting the country and
it's uh we just recently or congress is
recently discussing the next What's
called the dock fix which is when there
was a statute back in the late '90s I
guess that said we're going to reduce
the per fee rate for services Congress
always manages to pass a temporary bump
up so that that day never come so right
right right right and so you have uh the
Dynamics of Washington is that every
special interest sees its role is simply
preserving its benefits so no one can
ever claw any anything back and what
needs to happen is to abandon the feif
for service model right and by the way
people know this it's not a surprise I
mean even U the Affordable Care Act
so-call Obamacare has Provisions in it
that says we need to move to what they
call Integrated care providers where
doctors and hospitals will do everything
required for a patient for a fixed
annual fee rather than piling it up and
we can already see you know how you
would game that because we've had
experience with hmos in the past which
one of the ways that you do that is you
get the money and then you give out less
service that that that's right so you
have to have a better accountability
mechanism but the one thing uh well two
things that are needed I mean that the
healthc care is hard because there's a
kind of infinite demand for the services
so so if there's not a market mechanism
to deter
use and there's not an accountability
mechanism to make sure sure that for if
it's a fixed fee people are actually
delivering the services then there's a
lot of room for well here's I mean I
guess this is implicit in what we're
talking about but you know your book is
focused on government because you know
it's not that large corporations don't
have bureaucratic nightmares and stupid
rules that seemingly are issued by
nobody but enforced by everyone or
responsible to nobody but it's the
government and how much of this is is
fundamentally a question of the public
sector because the public sector is not
spending its own money or is not you
know when you talk about what we need as
a you know if we had a market mechanism
why don't we have a market in health
care say uh well it it is a government
problem corporations do lots of stupid
things but sooner or later they fail
right and so it gets cleaned out and you
and you've seen that with lots of
companies that just can't sustain their
their their pattern Western Union yeah
AT&T they're either gone or a shadow of
their former self because they're
beholden they're Shackled by their own
ltitude and and the nice thing about
corporations they may have stupid rules
but you put a new person in charge and
they're in charge they can change the
rules right yeah new boards new
shareholders and you see lots of
shareholder activism all the time this
sort of pushing companies to to to do
something that that if they didn't have
that sort of uh pressure account ility
they would not well they would not yeah
and let's talk about this because in in
the book in the rule of nobody you talk
about how under current Orthodoxy the
ideal government runs like a software
program input the facts and outcomes a
decision you write this technocratic
model of the rule of law has many
plausible virtues government can't act
arbitrarily uh if you know if if it's
Shackled by clear rules Precision will
offer predictability needed for citizens
to plan their Affairs and it's
unadulterated this the this type of
technocratic rule the the theory goes is
unadulterated by human judgment but it
comes at a cost um talk a little bit
about where did the technocratic model
come from why did it why did it kind of
gain dominance or hemony in the way that
things are done well it's an extremely
good question because uh having
government that kind of works like a
software program or automatic government
appeals to everybody it appeals to me
you know who wants want some official to
have discretion to do something you know
who knows what they might do and this
includes this is everything from a a a
building permit like you shouldn't have
to you know Kiss the Ring of a building
inspector or to just get a permit or a
cop to get a gun permit or I mean you
could multiply this at every level you
know teachers uh teacher Authority
principal Authority and and the worse
government works the more distrust there
is nobody trusts the teacher anymore or
the principal anymore the cop anymore so
we try to put in more rules to make sure
they do the right thing the problem is
it doesn't work it's its appeal is
undeniable it just doesn't work it's not
predictable rule of law supposed to be
predicted there too many rules yeah it's
just not predictable they they end up
contradicting each other nobody knows
what they are and so instead of
supporting Freedom now increasingly
people assume they can't do things they
assume they don't have freedom so there
must be a rule somewhere there have been
studies that confirmed that teachers and
principles don't act they don't maintain
order because they assume they can't you
that's well and you tell a story about a
teacher who starts at a school and they
call uh they call up the maintenance
person because the water uh the the
water fountain isn't working right and
they get chewed out for not following
the proper way water fountain repair uh
procedures yeah you know who's going to
go find the water fountain you know
repair procedures you know it's like
nothing nothing is based on common sense
nothing is based on the idea what's the
right thing to do everything is what is
a rule required well you know it seems
in in certain aspects of law or or
government there is a push back on this
kind of te technocratic rule I mean uh
surprisingly to some there's a number of
kind of libertarian or conservative
Republicans who are pushing back on
mandatory minimum sentencing which was
enacted precisely to say okay we're
removing the judges uh latitude to make
decisions here because you know that
that's not right the rule of law should
be equal treatment for equal offenders
um at the same time and this I guess is
a story that's in the news there's a
dupon named Roger Richards IV who uh was
just he was found guilty of raping his
children uh but the judge uh said well
you know what we're not going to give
him jail time because he wouldn't
farewell in prison isn't I mean this is
and I'm not ask you to comment on that
particular case but that's one of the
places where these dictatorial rules
Come from right because you don't want
well because he's a dupon he can buy
Justice you know we want equal laws
applied to equally to all people so the
ideal system of government the ideal
system of justice is one that people
reasonably trust it's not one that
guarantees the right result every time
it's one that people reasonably trust
and so if if the ultimate purpose of law
is to provide a framework for Freedom so
that people when they go through the day
feel free to interact with others um
both protected against abuse like fraud
or theft from others and also reasonably
confident that if they act reasonably
right you know they won't get in trouble
right and so we don't have that rule of
law now government doesn't act that way
and and people are increasingly insecure
America is now 20th in the world in ease
of starting a business you know because
of all
the you can curse this is this is a
Libertarian area you can curse so it's
it's really um so the system isn't
working but but giving people the
freedom to make judgments doesn't mean
they will make the right judgments but
in criminal
sentencing
because what happened was by trying to
take away discretion you actually ended
up giving discretion to less trustworthy
people the prosecutors who would game
the indictments to maximize the sentence
under the rigid sentencing guidelines so
that they effectively had could put a
gun to the Head even of an
innocent defendant because they're
looking they're staring they're looking
at a life sentence for some modest
alleged crime because of the way the
prosecutor organized the indictment
right well who do we trust more the
prosecutor is's trying to make himself
look good and has one interest or a
judge who at least is impartial right
and so sure judges will sometimes do the
wrong thing and sometimes there's a way
of dealing with that well well you talk
about you know Finding The Sweet Spot
between you know uh absolute discretion
which is kind which is tyranny of one
form un discre yeah or absolute rule you
know being bound by rules which is
another form of tyranny how do how do we
know when we're at that place um you
know is is there a particular time in
history that we should look at or how do
how do we know that we're not fooling
ourselves by giving government workers
discretion
well I think it's a I actually see these
as structural points um
um I think
law talk about Authority no one should
have unfettered authority to do whatever
they want and and frankly really no one
does I mean there's too many people
around each decision but but but the law
for an official ought to have goals and
principles it's like a Corral and within
that Corral the cop on the be
has the freedom to say well I'm not
going to arrest that person for
jaywalking because everyone in New York
City jaywalks you know then we would
every all of us would be in jail right
um I'm going to keep my focus on on
crimes that people think are more
important even though jaywalking is
illegal and so so within the Corral if
you
will of of an official's responsibility
the the teacher ought to have
responsibility The Authority in my view
to remove a disruptive student from the
classroom immediately without any legal
process without having to prove its
reasonableness you know you're not
sending the person to jail you're
sending them out of the classroom but
then there should be reviews so that if
they're if they're only sending out
students of a particular race or a
particular ethnicity or gender or this
or that Absol and so nobody should have
unfetter discretion again I said they're
bounded by by by principles and goals so
then who decides you know what
whether they're adhering to the
principal goals well there has to be
someone else with authority to use their
judgment an independent person about
whether this person is acting fairly or
not in the school it might be a parent
teacher committee you might have
independent people um in U um for an
inspector of a nursing
home that's first the
supervisor uh who could oversee it but
ultimately there's a court if somebody's
acting trying to shut down a nursing
home you know for the wrong reasons or
they didn't pay a bribe MH uh we have a
court system that says well that would
be illegal it's clearly unreasonable it
clearly exceeds the authority of the
person you know to to demand a bribe or
or indeed to act arbitrarily so so
nobody should ever have unfettered
discretion we ought to maintain all
these sort of checks and balances but
the critical point is the checks and
balances also depend on judgment M
there's no kind of
automatic put the piece of paper in and
the right answer pops up is that um you
know is is that a particular kind of
disease or or delusion of kind of
postwar America I mean you know of of a
kind of computer you know I'm thinking
of like in the 1950s or 60s of like well
you know you would you would see these
Geniuses with mainframe computers behind
them with the wheels kind of you know
and we have Punch Cards and you know
it's scientific management and we're
moving we we're recognizing the limits
of that model completely it's really
completely it's interesting that that so
I've was talking with some senior people
that Google about this um software
programs are built to be adaptable
they're they're they're actually the
smart programs and the algorithms they
build into them are all extremely
adaptable they allow people to approach
problems from different ways they allow
them to adjust to different other other
programs and systems we've built a legal
system that's completely rigid right
wrong right so it's it's it's it's
binary and it's ultimate sense I me it's
it's either legal or illegal and so we
we weigh everybody down with increasing
numbers of these chains right and then
wonder why nobody's getting anywhere we
can't rebuild a road or a bridge or or
maintain order order in the classroom
let's talk a little bit about how we
change the current uh system in the in a
chapter uh titled restoring human
control of democracy you're right
America is overdue for a shift in values
away from automatic government and
toward a structure that allows humans to
make choices needed to adapt to local
needs and Global challenges my vision is
this overthrow the bureaucracy and
return to a system based on human
responsibility that's a great slogan I
could see it in a movie about the 60s U
or the 70s or the 80s or the 90s you
know it could be at the Berlin Wall it
could be uh at the beginning of Arab
Spring how do we how do we create a
shift in human values a shift and values
away from automatic government and and
towards human Choice well um ultimately
we have to convince the public right
that this vision of automatic government
which appeals to everybody is
dysfunctional that it's undermined their
own Freedom at the same time that it's
made U government dysfunctional and that
you and part of that is first is is
popular obviously this is the long
conversation you've been having in your
public life of you know that there is a
system of government in place which
relies on this kind of technocratic
model and it doesn't work it doesn't
work we wanted to eliminate human choice
so you combine uh this early Industrial
Revolution notion of Scientific
Management where everything is told
everybody's told how to do things you
combine that it didn't it didn't work
the way they thought it was going to
work but the idea is you don't want the
guy the third guy in a five-step
assembly process suddenly freelancing
and saying oh I'm going to start doing
absolutely so there's there absolutely a
role to organization and and um I'll get
to that in a second and then we come to
the 1960s where we woke up to all these
abuses they were abuses racism sexism
pollution other things and we wanted to
create a system of government where no
one would have the authority to make bad
choices anymore MH so you marry that
idea with scientific management and you
get this model of incredible
micro regulation where all of a sudden
Rule books go from a forest ranger used
to have a little pamphlet with like 10
pages in it what his guidelines were
they became thousands of pages right and
this coincided with with our Awakening
that we needed more government oversight
over things like pollution and other
things and so those rules started being
written uh in a kind of micro regulatory
way telling everyone exactly how to do
everything yeah you liken it kind to the
Napoleonic Code where you know instead
of a general principle it seems like at
every point you want to you want to
imagine every possible permutation of
every situation and have a rule well
actually we can talk about that the the
Napoleonic Code looked at in hindsite
was a set of principles right and and
was not with most cases you know a set
of detailed rules they purport purported
to be clear law quot clear law right but
it relied on Concepts like
reasonableness and good faith you know
just like you know generally law La law
has to and so we started this this
almost orgy of rule writing and and and
and lawmaking and whenever possible we
made law unequivocal so there could be
no judgment so when the special aded
laws were passed because there had been
shameful abuse of disabled
children it was passed in 1975 it gave
um a uh a right without any payment of
each parent to an individualized
education for their child well has that
evolved that right evolved over the
decades now special ed consumes over 25%
of the total K to2 budget in this
country for the tiny proportion of
children well less than 10% who really
need it has been kind of overused um and
there's nothing for gifted children
almost nothing for pre- Education well
who's the decided that 25% of the budget
is the right balance between all these
different educational needs and the
answer to that is nobody has it just
took a life of its own it's like a
runaway train so apart from kind of
publicizing this growth in automatic
government and the deleterious effects
what's next then what are because you
talk about structural reforms I mean
this is not something you don't expect
you know cancer to cure itself you don't
expect a rotten government to fix itself
you know the the Berlin Wall wasn't
pulled down with the help of the ger you
know the the gdr it was in spite of it
so what are the structural reforms that
will will you know follow a change in
values that need to be put well we need
a new vision and and the structural
reform are a radical
simplification of almost every area of
government it is beyond the capacity uh
of a legislature to do this it violates
the laws of legislative physics to for a
body of hundreds of people to to
negotiate that is not small ball like
you can't we're going to we're not going
to fix tax policy or anything by saying
okay let's let's Tinker over here um is
it I mean you you talk about
Constitutional Amendments I'm not fully
sure if you're kind of being slightly
ironic or not but what you're calling
for is a kind of we need to clear the
decks right history says that when when
societies need change when the when the
inertial forces drive a society to a
point where it's close to paralysis or
dysfunction the change is never small
ball it's always big sometimes it's bad
big right the French Revolution was not
great the Arab Spring has ended up in a
being a kind of nightmare so far uh the
American Revolution was great uh but
none of those things are are are small
ball right the the advantage of what are
known as
rectifications which have happened
periodically through history like with
the like with the Napoleonic Code like
with the Uniform Commercial Code in the
1950s we took this massive uh commercial
law in all the states and and uh turned
them into a uniform commercial code that
everybody so everybody could contract
with each other reasonably confident
what what set the table for that I mean
Are there specific moments uh you know
so for instance at at reason we talk a
lot about the uh uh the deregulation of
Interstate Trucking and airline travel
in the uh in the 70s which was an
interesting uh coming together of people
on the left you know Ralph nater and Ted
Kennedy along with right-wing uh
economists um what happened that the
universal Commercial Code was able to
happen well you had a business interest
saying uh having a dis discombobulated
contract law was standing in the way of
progress and then you had labor groups
also saying this is standing in the way
of jobs and in progress so you you were
able to get coal
of people including leading contract law
experts everyone saw that having a kind
of jungle you know kind of an Amazonian
jungle for contract law made no sense it
need to be clear and understandable so
they came together to fix it what's
needed today is a similar understanding
that a much bigger Amazonian Jungle of
bureaucracy that we built up over the
last 50 years mainly has a similar
effect it's paralyzing the society and
it's in everyone's interest except
perhaps for isolated special interest
well and or or large the the their
speaker or their agents in the in
Congress say I mean you write the odds
are about zero that the Democratic party
will abandon say the perquisites of
public employees unions the odds are
also low that the Republican party will
accept the need for a more flexible
government so you know you you talk say
for instance in in the set of amendments
that you suggest as a way of clearing
the thicket uh things like the president
would actually be given more control
over the Executive Branch hiring and
firing decision setting agendas um you
know how will that happen it will only
happen when there's a when there's
public demand and so the the
Washington Washington works perfectly
well on its own terms it's it's inside a
bubble mold is grown over it the mold
are all these special interest and and
the money that goes back and forth and
there's a tug of war that keeps
everybody employed and nothing much
changes right so why do they want to put
their jobs at risk whoever they are you
know by actually going to a better
system it's never going to happen until
we actually put outside pressure to
disrupt it and you you talk about that
there's a you know this is the the need
for reform is actually a moral
imperative for Citizens not for
politicians right right and so um we the
citizenry have gotten used to and it
probably get some pleasure out of shod
and for you know out of how stupid
government works thank God we don't work
for government you know look at how bad
they are the problem is it's now
affecting our lives we can't start our
business I can't our kids can't even
have a lemonade stand you know there's
uh the teacher can't maintain order in
the classroom it's affecting us
everywhere and our taxes are going up
and our kids are going to go bankrupt
because of the money we're spending on
Medicare do you um I mean are you
favorably expose then towards groups
like the tea party which seem to be
shaking things up and you may not agree
with their agenda however that we Define
that but I mean is that the type of
outside energy that needs to be directed
well yes that energy is very
constructive and um I you know my um my
quibble with the Tea Party is that they
think the answer is to get rid of
government altogether and I agree and
argue here that basically every
government program broken but U while
there's some we certainly ought to get
rid of you know the subsidies from the
New Deal and stuff like that um you do
want oversight over nursing homes you do
want you know oversight over worker
safety but those programs are incredibly
ineffective for the reasons I stated and
and costly and inexpensive get in the
way of people doing the right thing
ultimately the uh the questions for a
working government and Society are do
people feel free to do what's right can
can government officials be practical
can they balance a budget can they can
they be fair it doesn't guarantee they
will be do you I mean as part of the
problem you know you're obviously we're
in a nice neighborhood in New York where
we're talking uh you're doing extremely
well and have you know things are hard
for you I mean you you might be in a
position to start a business but you can
also you can kind of create a wall
garden and you can throw as much money
as you need over the wall to evacuate
government you don't have to send your
kids to the local school you don't have
to send your parents to a public nursing
home or anything like that is you know
is it that people are now able and more
and more people are able to evacuate
government and government services and
so the pressure that would build if we
were all in this together is is just not
going to be there yeah I think that's a
fair point I think that the people who
have the resources to uh to to be more
effective as advocates for change don't
have don't have the imperative for
change I mean you know one day a few
months ago friend of mine came up to me
very successful businessman say gosh you
know that editor you wrote In The Wall
Street Journal it's just great it's just
great that you're doing this I said uh
to him well great well you should get
involved help me said said nah it's
hopeless you know and so so that's a you
know that's to me that's actually
immoral um and so what I argue in the
book is that uh the solutions here I
actually don't think are that hard
conceptually it is not hard to come up
with a model for environmental review
where it takes a year or two not a
decade or two Germany does it that way
Canada does it that way really easy you
give some official the authority to make
decide when's enough's enough and you
and you make it happen I could with the
possible exception of healthcare because
again this infinite demand and no Market
mechanism
every other program is actually really
easy to fix you simplify it you you know
you make it go and you talk I mean one
of the the truly obvious and simple
rules that you suggest in in your list
of amendments is that any law with a
budgetary impact would be sunsetted in
15 years so it has to come up for review
yes it has to come up because government
our Founders actually made a mistake
there you know there was this big debate
between the Federalist and the anti-
Federalist and the Anti Federalist
wanted to prevent the Federal feral
government from taking over
state state decisions so they made it
very hard to pass federal laws with all
the checks and
balances fine except 200 years later now
you've got all this siment in the harbor
so nobody can get anywhere all this law
and the same checks and balances apply
to get riding a law getting rid of a law
as it as to pass in the first place
except that now the law has an army of
special interest around it every single
law like the special ed law it's got
It's not money it's these special ed
Advocates who are zealots they'll chain
themselves your door
so so no one can actually get rid of a
law it's it's so in uh it's so unlikely
it's so difficult to actually amend a
law in any significant way that nobody
even thinks about it Congress doesn't
even know what their job anymore well
who else job it is you know all this law
who's in charge of whether it works or
not none of it works who's in charge
nobody
so so we have a constitutional problem
and so I propose a
sunset Clause where every law of
budgetary impact will sunset every 15
years and to avoid Congress just giving
lip service and reenacting it which has
been the experienced in some states Sun
it laws make it
constitutional and give an independent
commission the job of actually just
recommending what to do about it and
having that be presented to the public
before Congress can then act again so it
has a bogey against which it has to act
because otherwise but again it is I mean
on a certain level I mean there needs to
be structural reforms but in the end it
really depends on the will of the
citizen rate to say you know what enough
is enough or we share a vision of a
limited government uh you know that is
accountable talk a little bit in terms
of um uh you know how people help and
whatnot you're the uh president or chair
of the common good foundation talk a
little bit about that well
um it's very important as I argue in the
book that citizens get involved and your
point is that nothing's going to change
and if it does change nothing's still
going to work well unless citizens
actually take ownership for these issues
and feel like it's their job to help
make democracy work and now we've got a
kind of absentee government where where
the citizens Act yes in it and feel like
it's out of their control and it is
largely out of their control I mean it's
fascinating the budget just the federal
budget about 2third of it is fully was
what's called mandatory spending which
is on autopilot and then even a lot of
discretionary spending is on autopilot
yeah yeah it's it's um public solvency
is
illegal it's all been preset inlegal
concrete you know is it I mean basically
doing anything sensible is illegal right
because it's all it's all been you know
preet in law right so so citizens have
to get involved both in making this
happen and making sure it will continue
to happen our Founders knew that I mean
you know Benjamin Franklin said what
have you done he said well we've created
a republic if you can keep it right and
in in what he was saying is citizens
have to be involved so we actually need
to create new institutions citizen
institutions that are not designed to
take power but to put pressure on those
in power to make sure they actually are
doing their jobs those institions don't
exist how uh how does the common good
fit into that F Well the common good is
is uh what we've been doing we've been
in business a Dozen Years uh we create
new Visions for how law could actually
work better we had a joint Fisher with
the Harvard School of Public Health to
design a new system of justice for
Health Care basically to solve the
medical malpractice problem where we
waste you know h100 billion a year in
defensive medicine because doctors un
reasonably they reasonably don't don't
trust the system of justice because it's
just jury by jury so we would create a
system of expert Health courts and then
we built a coalition behind it
everybody's for it Romney's for it Obama
came out for it all the dead commission
the trial lawyers have stopped it so far
but it will happen uh now we're
redesigning the infrastructure approval
process and if we could get that pass we
have a couple of potential sponsors in
the Senate uh in the next uh year or two
we could hire 2 million Americans on do
doing infrastructure over the next four
or five years just by changing by
simplifying the infrastructure approval
process so we're in the business of
creating new Visions but what's needed
now and I argue in this book is the big
New Vision you know not the new vision
of just fixing this or that but a new
vision about how government could work
so uh what I'm my ambition for this book
is that um other groups Allied groups uh
including people who run the reason
foundation will will find common cause
in the need for big change and we'll
come together in a kind of a coalition
of the whole and say we may not agree on
what every solution is but what we can
all agree is this system of government
is really out of control well end with
uh you know take the facts and put them
into your computer uh what are the
what's the probability that big change
will happen over the next five years uh
I think the probability that big change
will happen over the next 10 years is
extremely high
um is that 20% is it 80% is it yeah I
75% okay and and and the reason big
change will happen it's not because of
what I do or you do or anybody else does
the reason it'll happen is because we'll
have a crisis and the current system is
truly
unsustainable and um and but what's
important when you have a crisis because
you don't want to end it have it end up
like the French Revolution you don't
want Occupy Wall Street to be in charge
um uh is it's very important to have a
new vision MH and if you have a new
vision then maybe you'll get leaders I'm
talking to former Governor MCH Daniels
about creating a new center at Purdue
where we would actually begin building a
vision block by block and go through
government programs and analyze how they
don't work and come up with models of
how they might work and and begin to
well and so this is the I believe it was
Milton Freedman who said that you know
the goal of people who trade in ideas
and and public policy is to make things
seem politically inevitable become or
rather politically impossible become
politically inevitable because when the
crisis comes people will be looking
around for okay will this work will this
work will this work right and so and so
what I'm arguing for ultimately here is
is a structure of government of the sort
that our Founders
contemplated where leaders are elected
they take
responsibility they actually act on
their values they don't try to avoid
their values they act on their values
because that's what we elected them for
and they succeed or fail and they're
held accountable and and the the model
all of life works on responsibility
everybody looking listening to this
program has achieved what they've
achieved in life because they took
responsibility to make it happen
government's no different than that
somebody's got to take
responsibility they'll fall down they
can be held accountable they'll pick
themselves up or somebody else will take
their place and if you can't be
practical you can't be fair you can't be
moral and you can't balance a budget and
that's where we are right now in this
state which means we're going to have to
rebuild it well we will leave it there
the book the new book by Philip K Howard
is the rule of nobody saving America
from dead laws and broken government
thanks for talking with us thank Nick
for reason TV I'm Nick
kesie